while the media fulminate about a
supposed coup the legal process moves
forward
media outlets push social media outlets
to censor conservatives and covet
hospitalizations hit record levels i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let others track what you do keep
yourself safe at expressvpn.com
ben first note happy veterans day thank
you to everyone who has stood between
those who would seek to destroy our
freedoms
and the protection of americans those
people are the line between freedom
and tyranny the line between
civilization and non-civilization so
find a veteran and thank a veteran today
if you're in our audience and you're a
veteran we thank you you are the best
among us for sure okay we're gonna get
to all the news
in just one moment first let us talk
about the fact that you're spending too
much on your cell phone bill what if
they're a company that gave you amazing
deals every day well that's what you get
with pure talk a veteran run wireless
company
think at t but much better who
understands what it means to serve you
verizon at t t-mobile if you're with
them you're overpaying pure and simple
pure talk can easily save you over 400 a
year see here's the thing when you buy
one of the other wireless programs what
you're getting
is unlimited data you don't need
unlimited data what you need is
unlimited talk text and two gigs of data
for just 20 bucks a month and if you go
over on data usage they don't charge you
for it switching to pure talk is the
easiest decision you're going to make
today you can keep your phone and your
number or you can get great deals on the
latest iphones and android
grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
and say ben shapiro when you do you save
off your first month style pound 250 say
keyword ben shapiro to get started
pure talk is simply smarter wireless
you're getting the same coverage you'd
get from any other
wireless network excellent coverage for
a lower price what exactly are you
waiting for
go check out puretalk usa today dial
pound 250 say
my name ben shapiro to get started and
say 50 off your first
month pure talk usa go check them out
right now okay so
right now the legal process continues
unabated there are lawsuits the lawsuits
have been filed they will be examined
by courts there are investigations that
are going on into voter fraud and voter
irregularity
we'll see how widespread these are and
yet everybody is in such a rush such a
rush so we've been told a few things one
we're being told this is a coup
and the media are very upset about this
this is a coup it's not a coup as we'll
explain in a second so usually a coup
requires you to actually violate the law
i'm sorry
not a single state has certified its
election result yet not a single elector
has voted yet
so what the hell are you talking about a
coup like what are you even saying
okay so that's narrative number one that
you are hearing narrative number two
you're hearing is well if the transit if
the transition isn't sped up right now
if trump doesn't concede and then speed
up the transition well then
clearly that's going to lead to dire
ramifications downline yeah bullcrap
okay so all of that comes from a 911
report the 911 commission report that
suggested
that because the transition from the
clinton administration to the bush
administration was delayed in 2000 that
somehow led to 911
that's nonsense the reality is that that
was a cover story for the fact that the
clinton administration basically let al
qaeda run wild
it was not about the transition the fact
is that there were serious governmental
problems that preceded the transition
there were serious governmental problems
after the transition before 9 11
but this idea that if trump doesn't turn
over the keys to the car to joe biden
today
that somehow the united states is in
innate danger joe biden doesn't have any
power until january 20th
it takes a little while to transition in
but he doesn't actually have any power
until january 20th even if
trump were to concede the election today
so
basically the media are now creating a
crisis where none exists and they're
steadfastly determined to have no sense
of humor about this entire thing
we have to see the media has been ramped
up to such an extent they've been the
media
yeah i don't like language with regard
to stealing elections or rigging
elections
but i think it is fair to say that the
media attempted to rig this election in
advance
that does not mean they changed the
process it means that they used all the
authority they could possibly wield
in order to lie to the american public
about a variety of narratives ranging
from russian collusion
to president trump's sole responsibility
for kovid and now
they're so ramped up they've been ramped
up since trump was elected in 2016
and now they're so ramped up that they
can't ramp back down
it's like after you spend 26 hours a
week you can't fall asleep
the media have been doing that right
they're hiring their own farts and they
can't get over it and so everything at
this point
is about the crisis now you might look
around and say yourself wait a second
there is no crisis
it turns out the vast majority of
americans are already pretty sanguine
about the election
if you look at the polling data right
now a lot of republicans are mistrusting
the system a lot of republicans are
upset about the system
but overall eight and ten americans
believe that the election is over only
three percent of americans by pulling
data believe
that donald trump will end up as
president of the united states on
january 20th
in other words people are coming to the
conclusions they want to come to there's
no violence in the streets by the way it
would have been precisely the opposite
of trump had won
but if trump had openly and obviously
won on election night they had boarded
up all the stores in the major cities
right there there would have been actual
street-level violence if donald trump
had won the election on election night
so spare me the hysterics about how the
united states is in the middle of an
anti-democratic meltdown
it is not even close to that but the
media have decided that because they
have to manufacture this narrative from
whole cloth that everything is in crisis
right we're in crisis mode
i'm asking you look around you today do
you see crisis seriously do you see
crisis wherever you are living
do you see people in the streets burning
things do you see people rioting and
looting
that's more than you could say six
months ago when democrats were egging on
people rioting and looting
do you see violence in the streets do
you see mayhem
do you see do you foresee a future in
which donald trump even after all the
legal challenges go through and let's
say that all the legal challenges are
rejected
and the election is certified do you see
donald trump holding up in the oval
office and snorting blow and firing
machine guns through the door and
shouting
say hello to my little friend do you see
that happening or do you see him leaving
in an orderly transition of power just
like every other president since the
foundation of the republic
can we get over ourselves in other words
but no we cannot because the media have
to
here's the thing the media their biggest
meta-narrative the biggest
meta-narrative of all
was probably the biggest lie which is
that trump was an overt threat to
american democracy
trump was a fascist he was orange hitler
and he was going to ruin american
democracy top to bottom
now those of us who watched the
political system closely
saw that we didn't like a lot of trump's
rhetoric but he was not a threat to the
systems like in any way shape or form in
fact he was much less of a threat to the
system
than barack obama right barack obama
utilized widespread executive orders in
dramatically
in dramatically extensive ways that
trump never touched barack obama
actually went after journalists like
his own doj wiretapped journalists
barack obama was the president who
militarized his irs
against conservatives by essentially
implying they should do it then they
went ahead and they did it
and barack obama did threaten some of
the foundational
institutions of the republic donald
trump really did not
it was the outgoing obama administration
that politicized its intelligence
agencies to go after people
like michael flynn without any actual
legal basis for doing so
so spare me all of this donald trump was
a fact but here's the thing the media
have been so invested in the notion
that donald trump is hitlerian that even
after they believe that he has lost the
election and even though they know
that if trump is found to have lost the
election here he is going to leave in an
orderly transition to power
they have to maintain the fiction
because otherwise it turns out they've
been full of crap for years
if it turns out that donald trump
complained
says that he didn't win the election
says he didn't lose the election
complains it was voter fraud and voter
irregularity but he leaves and turns
over the keys and nothing else happens
it turns out that he was not a threat to
the republic he never was a threat
to the republic and the media can't
handle that because if that's true then
the media
just went hog wild hysterical over
almost literally nothing
they are not heroes they are not
democracy dies in darkness
they are just a bunch of hysterical
minis who spend their days
wrapping themselves up in the mantle of
protecting democracy
while actually just screaming at the
moon that's what they and so they have
to maintain that fiction so that's what
we're getting today
the first indicator this was happening
uh well not the first indicator but the
most obvious indicator this was
happening yesterday
was secretary of state mike pompeo did a
presser at that presser
he was asked about transition of power
and he made a joke it is
perfectly obvious this is a joke like
incredibly obvious this is a joke he
smiles at the end and people
laugh i understand that members of the
left have an investment in pretending
they don't understand drugs it's one of
the great
irritants of my of my life in the
industry that i am in
i will tell a joke the media will
steadfastly insist i did not tell a joke
critique the joke and then say that it
would have been funny if it had been a
joke
that's the way all of this works but if
i do a 10-minute segment
uh a humor segment reading straight the
lyrics to whap
this is treated as though i am perfectly
serious right now this is the way that
the media
treats any conservative who tells a joke
okay so mike pompeo
tells a joke yesterday right this is a
joke he is joking it is perfectly
obvious he is joking
now i'm not a person who dismisses
straight statements
as jokes when they're not jokes this is
clearly a joke okay and then not only is
it
a joke he follows up by explaining that
there will be an orderly transition of
power
the media decided what mike pompeo is
actually saying is there will be no
orderly transition to power
and that he and donald trump are going
to call in the tanks
to defend the white house from the from
the invasion of joe biden
here's the actual clip you tell me
whether you think that mike pompeo is
joking here he is obviously joking here
there will be a smooth transition to a
second trump administration
all right we're ready the world is
watching what's taking place here we're
going to count all the votes
when the process is complete there'll be
electors selected there's a process the
constitution lays it out pretty clearly
the world should have every confidence
that the transition necessary to make
sure that the state department is
functional today
successful today and successful with the
president who's
in office on january 20th a
mid-afternoon
will also be successful okay that last
statement is exactly what democrats have
been asking mike pompeo to say
and every other republican there will be
a smooth transition of power that first
statement
is clearly a joke right he's joking that
there's going to be a transition to a
second trump term and then he moves on
to and then
whoever the president is there will be a
smooth transition right that's what he
says
the media lost their bleep over this
they lost their bleep how dare mike
pompeo that's not a joke
he's probably serious probably mike
pompeo is gonna
call out the proud boys and they're
gonna hold themselves up in the oval
office
or alternatively you guys are hysterical
ridiculous people hysterical ridiculous
people because everyone on both sides of
the aisle is saying the same thing
they are everyone is saying there's a
legal process the legal process will be
carried forward
and guess what when the legal process is
over one of these two people
is going to be president of the united
states or president's elect of the
united states and then we're going to
move forward because that's how it works
that's how it works gang everybody knows
this except the mainstream media which
again are invested in the false
narrative then we are on the verge of
watching democracy melt down
they are invested in that narrative
because that's the narrative they've
been pushing for four years if it turns
out that democracy did not melt down
during trump's term and will not melt
down if there is a transition from
trump's term it turns out they were just
over liars for four years and they can't
handle that
so instead they'll just keep lying
better to maintain the fiction than to
acknowledge the reality okay in just one
second we'll get to more of this
because it turns out that republicans
are being straightforward about this
there's a legal process it will be
fulfilled
and if there's a transition of power
called for there will be a transition of
power we'll get some more of that
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that businesses have had
to be pretty flexible this year from
working remotely to pivoting their
business models for long-term
survival and growth if you're in charge
of hiring for your business these pivots
have made your job even more challenging
especially if you have to hire for brand
new roles thankfully there's one place
you can always count on to make hiring
faster and easier ziprecruiter.com
dailywire it is a great place to ensure
that if you have to replace an employee
for example
then you are able to do so in quick and
easy fashion
and improve your employment around the
office
like let's say for example that you have
a uh employee she's just fabulous her
name is savannah
and let's say that she's really terrific
but there's only one problem
she she tends to send over the ads like
very late in the morning so you don't
actually get to take a look at the ads
until like right before like right
before
the actual broadcast and so it's
slightly confusing for you well then you
might think to yourself well maybe you
have to replace savannah and then you
check out ziprecruiter.com
so right now try this recruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com dailywire that is
zip recruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e let zip recruiter take
hiring off your plate so you can focus
on growing your business go to zip
recruiter dot com
daily wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire go check them out
right now ziprecruiter.com
dailywire already so it's not just mike
pompeo who's saying the perfectly
obvious mitch mcconnell is saying that
perfectly obvious
mitch mcconnell the senate majority
leader who is going to be the check
against joe biden if uh in fact joe
biden is
inaugurated in january mitch mcconnell
says
of course there's going to be a
transition i don't know why you guys are
are so
eager and and freaking out like what
exactly is going on that is that has got
your knickers in a twist
i don't think we're going to have an
interrupted
transition to whoever is the next
administration i think we ought to quit
all the hand-wringing
and not act like this is extraordinary
we're going to get through this period
and we'll swear in the winter
on january the 20th 2021 just like we
have
every four years since 1793.
okay well um so what's the controversy
here i'm just i'm just confused what
exactly is the controversy here
there is no controversy here you know
who else says there's no controversy
here see this is the funny thing about
the
supposedly incoming biden administration
biden's gonna say stuff and everybody's
just gonna ignore him
right biden is just the old man sitting
in the corner just happy to be there
right like he's so happy biden right now
because he thinks he won the presidency
and so he's just sitting over in the
corner and everybody is ignoring him
like he has nothing of relevance to say
the media are angry because they don't
actually want to listen to joe biden
when joe biden says there will be a
smooth and orderly transition and this
is really not that big a deal
right biden said the obligatory words
about how trump is a poor sport and how
he should just concede
but then he was asked about the
transition and biden's like yeah there
will be a transition
even joe biden is like you guys are like
can everybody just calm the hell down a
little bit
like the election happened last tuesday
it is eight days later
okay it turns out again not a single
state is going to certify
its vote until next week at the very
earliest
and not a single elector is going to
vote until mid-december so just call
your jets even joe biden is like you got
like what's the crisis here exactly like
i might find it annoying i might find it
irritating but is it a crisis
a constitutional government here's joe
biden telling everybody to cool it and
then the media just ignoring him because
joe biden has been irrelevant since the
start continues to be irrelevant and
will be irrelevant throughout his
administration
we are already beginning the transition
we're well underway
and the ability uh for
uh the administration in any way by
failure to recognize us
as our win uh does not uh
change the dynamic at all and what we're
able to do so i'm confident that uh
the fact that they're not willing to
acknowledge we want at this point
is uh not of much consequence in our
planning and what we're able to do
between now
and january 20th okay so that is joe
biden
literally saying none of this is a big
deal and then the media are like no it's
a huge deal a huge
deal is this is all fantasy land crap
from from the media
so here's some of the media overreaction
so frank felizzi who's a former fbi
official
who appears on msnbc to say hysterically
wrong things he appeared with nicole
wallace
on msnbc where he explained that
essentially you are now
seeing the predicate to a barricaded
subject in the white house
so he literally thinks that donald trump
is going to do the scarface routine
he literally thinks that donald trump is
going to go out there and he's going to
grab some barbed wire
and he's going to start stringing it
along the front of the white house
and then he's going to hole up in there
with an rpg here's frank philiuzzi
an actual paid contributor at msnbc
saying a silly silly thing
well we're coming very close to having
what the bureau calls a barricaded
subject
the barricaded subject is in the white
house and what we saw the
president the president-elect do today
was
right on the money with regard to
initial negotiation
with a barricaded subject you want to
let that barricaded subject know that
this is going to be okay i'm going to
listen to what you have to say you can
vent
invent invent you can call me names and
not acknowledge my authority
outside the perimeter here but
eventually we're going to get this done
and eventually in this case nicole
there's going to be a time where
joe biden calls the swat team what in
the actual hell is he talking about like
it's a hostage negotiation
what it's like waco is what you're
saying
like it's ruby ridge or waco is what
frank felizzi is saying
he's not being hysterical at all that is
a perfectly objective
newsy take over on msnbc i'm supposed to
respect
these media outlets i'm supposed to
pretend that these people are
truth-tellers they're objective news
journalists
come the hell on come the hell on
i mean honestly that's really funny like
the fact that members of msnbc are like
he's just like a barricaded subject i
mean it's just like a man who's taking
his wife hostage and threatening to
shoot her in the face
what we have to do is we have to have a
hostage negotiation and the best hostage
negotiator i know
is the senile old man in the corner
talking to the tree
okay frankfully uzi thank you for that
that very very newsy update from msnbc
here and get some more of this in just
one second because again
the narrative that's being crafted in
real time is that we have to rush we
have to rush
because we don't rush there'll be a coup
there's no coup there's no rush
everything is fine calm your ass is down
here more of this
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that when you look around
your house what you see is a lot of nice
stuff right your house looks pretty nice
but something seems a little dingy you
know what it is
it's your window coverings yep now
you're looking around now you see it
don't you you're like oh shapiro's right
this is why you should go check out
blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home
with easy online ordering and free
shipping the experts at blinds.com
understand
that window treatments are one of those
household items you don't just think
about they can make a huge impact on the
look and feel
of your home you don't need to do a full
renovation by simply changing what's on
your windows you can change the way
light comes into your home which is a
huge thing you can create a totally
different feel blinds.com has helped
millions of homeowners through the
process plus they guarantee the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or have
them measure
and install everything for you we've
been using blinds.com at our new home it
is just fabulous go right now see how
much you can save
at blinds.com when you check out online
don't forget to tell them you heard
about blinds.com from
this the greatest of all shows the ben
shapiro show rules and restrictions
may apply go right now check out
blind.com
make your house look better do it for
the best possible price and again they
guarantee the perfect fit
check them out right now blinds.com and
make sure that when you check out you
let them know that we sent you
the ben shapiro show sent you go check
them out alrighty so
jesse wegman has an opinion piece today
a member of the editorial board of the
new york times
which of course is basically
justalon.com at this point he has a
piece today titled the republican party
is attacking a democracy
our survival as a nation depends above
all on the loser accepting the results
of an election
okay well the results of the election
are not yet clear okay the results of
the election have not yet been certified
not one state has certified a vote now
one elector has voted
it would be a threat to democracy if say
we went through this entire legal
process
and the election was certified and all
the electors voted and then trump was
like i'm not leaving
right then you would have a
constitutional crisis there is no
indicator that this is going to happen
but it doesn't matter the media again
have to spin this narrative that trump
was always a threat to democracy and
that justified us being absolute
horrific garbage at our job
it justified a silencing dissent it
justified us reporting rumor it
justified us reporting anonymous
bullcrap for years because after all if
you're reporting on orange hitler you
have to make sure that you stop orange
hitler by any means necessary
and now when it appears that trump might
leave office
they have to re-examine all of their
premises wait a second hitler never left
office
right see the hallmark of dictators is
that they don't leave the hallmark of
dictators is that if they are challenged
they liquidate their dissenters
but trump isn't doing any of that so one
of two things is true either the media
are a bunch of liars who spun out this
bizarre narrative
and now are forced to confront that fall
city
or trump actually is going to be orange
hitler and that in the end
donald trump is going to call in the
jack boots so they're just going to
continue playing in this fantasy land i
mean it really is an incredible thing
they are so stuck in their own heads
that they can't get out
so jesse wegman says it turns out there
was a coordinated attack on the 2020
election after all
it began several years ago and
accelerated in the last several months
now that election day has passed it has
launched into overdrive its weapons are
baseless insinuation
and evidence-free charges deployed
solely to soak chaos and undermine the
results of a free and fair election one
that produced a clear winner and an even
clearer loser
but the most dangerous attackers are not
the russians or the chinese
they are the leaders of the republican
party in the face of a commanding
national triumph by president-elect
joe biden not just an electoral college
victory but a popular vote margin
approaching 5 million
president trump and top republicans are
behaving like spoiled children
refusing to let go of their toys now i
have a question
um stacey abram governor georgia right
no
no bueller hillary clinton
right legit presidents of the united
states in 2016 donald trump illegitimate
russian collusion facebook's fault etc
i'm just i'm not willing to hear that it
is a deep and abiding threat to
democracy when people use the legal
process
in order to challenge a vote so just to
be straight about this the media's take
is that if the entire intelligence
apparatus is mobilized in order to
investigate a bull crap claim of russian
collusion
that is not in fact a coup and if you
say it's a coup you're really bad but
it is a coup if you file a lawsuit that
goes to court and then you abide by the
results
i don't think you know what the word cou
means you asshats i really don't
i don't think you know what what any of
this means i don't think you know what
fascism means i don't think you know
what ku means i don't think you know
what any of this means
so what is their proof that the coup is
happening the proof is that republicans
won't congratulate joe biden now i am
unaware of a constitutional provision
that says that you have to congratulate
a person who is not yet officially the
president-elect
okay joe biden he is projected to be the
right that is true it is true that
donald trump has a heavy legal burden in
order to demonstrate
voter fraud sufficient to overturn
election results all of that is true
it is true that if you had to place
money on it right now joe biden is the
most likely person to be taking the oath
of office on january 20th
but if you had the bet that is true none
of that means
that there is anything mandating that
people say that joe biden is
president-elect now
or that or that or that president trump
can see the election before all of the
legal challenges are exhausted
especially if he believes that there is
serious voter fraud and yet
this is the proof the proof of fascism
is not that trump is holding up in the
oval office
and preparing the brigades the proof of
fascism is that ron johnson
won't say congratulations to joe biden
if that's if that's your proof of
fascism guys i
have a feeling that you really don't
know what fascism is here was an msnbc
reporter haranguing
various republicans for not saying
congratulations to joe biden because
again apparently according to article
79 of the constitution of the united
states if republican senators refuse to
congratulate
the projected winner of an election
three weeks
before the actual electoral vote well
that means that there's a coup underway
everybody on red alert def con one gang
here is msnbc harassing republican
senators
did vice president biden win the
election it'll play out
but we'll know when the electors come to
town and it's official
senators did vice president biden win
the election
we don't know yet was there any fraud in
your race as far as you know
i don't believe so iowa has a really
great election system
and i i trust the integrity of our
process
if you suspect fraud anywhere else um i
i can't speak to that have you spoken to
vice president biden yet
i have not do you believe he won the
election
okay so and and they won't say they
won't say if they believe he won the
election well
a coup a coup so bran aquila over at cnn
i was in the gym when this was playing
yesterday and even i was like come
on come on should this whole harangue
about how terrible it was that
republican senators
would not actually congratulate joe
biden and then she showed a list
of the various republican senators who
had not congratulated joe biden
here and by the way the chiron on this
read trump's defiance fueled by enablers
like barr
mcconnell fox now remember brianna
keeler is not supposed to be
a a an opinion host right she is not
supposed to be rachel maddow
right if this were rachel maddow thing
i'd be like okay whatever that's that's
okay understood but
she's not right she's she's in she's an
objective journalist
journalism over at cnn the chiron reads
trump's defiance fueled by enablers like
barr
mcconnell fox i mean that's pure opinion
there is
there's in no way that that is not a
factual statement
okay first of all defiance fueled right
these are all opinion terms
they're fueled by enabling how do you
know any of this this is your opinion
maybe it's good opinion maybe it's true
opinion maybe it's wrong opinion i don't
know
but but one thing is for sure you are
not in any way an objective journalist
and i am unaware of the constitutional
provision that suggests gop senators
have to congratulate joe biden
and that if they don't we declare a coup
and roll in the tanks to stop donald
trump
he was brianna keeler yesterday the
republican senators
who are still silent about biden's win
they're enablers too
and here is the list we're going to
leave this up for a second because it is
rather long but if the gop senator is
not named romney
sas murkowski or collins they're on this
list
where the sound of silence is more
abundant than that simon and garfunkel
song where the duo wrote about silent
masses who didn't use their voices quote
and the people bowed and prayed to the
neon god they made
end quote that they made these senators
who are not powerless
they're just afraid of the consequences
of using their power which is
where courage comes in and so far at
least they lack the courage
to serve their country over their party
so much objective journalism
right there you know the hallmark of
objective journalism is when in the
middle of a news report you start
quoting simon and garfunkel lyrics
that is definitely the the mark of
objective journalism i can't count the
number of times
walter cronkite randomly launched into
rolling stone's lyrics
just just for for no reason by the way
if that is your height of cultural
reference
move on move on brianna she got mad at
me for pointing this out yesterday
she she got very angry at me on twitter
for pointing out that this was a very
very silly segment and that she in fact
is masquerading
as a as a as an objective journalist
she tweeted at me she said no i said it
shows a lack of courage prioritizing the
country and i'll add to that here class
all of which republicans have
historically prided themselves on if
you're gonna quote me quote me tweet
storming a straw man is a weak move i
didn't quote her
i literally just said that there's no
constitutional provision mandating
that people congratulate a person who is
not yet president-elect i tweeted back
that's all fine opinion it is not
objective journalism
i also don't remember the same umbrage
regarding say governor stacey abrams of
georgia
no reply from briana keeler at this hour
we'll bring you all updates
in just a second we'll get to more media
malfeasance because here's the thing
this is now being spun into an attack on
any news that democrats don't like
which is not a shock we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about your safety and security so i'm
deeply concerned always about safety and
security unfortunately i receive
more than my share of death threats and
that is why i've relied for my security
on ring for literally
years not only that i have small
children my small children run around
the house and they clock themselves
i can't keep an eye on all of them at
once but with my ring cameras i
definitely definitely can
there are a thousand reasons why
protecting your home matters to you ring
has security products for every corner
of your home inside and out best of all
you can see it all in one simple app
with ring
you can keep an eye on your home no
matter where you are right from your
phone if someone stops by or if
something is going on
ring will let you know it's peace of
mind anytime knowing your home is
protected
whatever you call home ring has
everything you need to protect it see
and speak to whoever is at your door
from anywhere with video doorbells keep
an eye on every corner of your house
with easy to install indoor and outdoor
cams protect your whole home
with ring alarm a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install yourself get a special
offer
on the ring welcome kit right now at
ringgit.com
it comes with rings video doorbell 3 and
the chime pro it is the perfect way to
start your ring experience go to
ring.com once more that is ring.com
for the special deal alrighty so
here's the reality the media of course
are invested in the narrative that this
is a constitutional crisis
and something deeply horrible is going
on unless everybody congratulates joe
biden
i do love brianna keeler of cnn
suggesting that the republicans who have
historically prided themselves on class
and decency they're acting in an
unclassy way yeah i remember all those
times cnn gave republicans credit for
being classy remember that
do you remember that no because it never
happened yeah me neither
oh don lemon kind of let the cat out of
the bag uh last night on cnn
he basically said listen you have to
give us some time to get over this and
that's what's happening right here
the media need trump the media love
trump they need him because he makes
them feel so good about themselves
they get to claim that big orange hitler
over here justifies anything they do
they can be just
as bad as they want to be because after
all they are just policing
policing the most dangerous threat to
the republic
and well now the prospect is
that donald trump will not be president
in january and the media are the ones
who are pushing that prospect
so now they're stuck in this this kind
of awkward place where
they want to cover donald trump they
need to cover donald trump
but they're looking at a future where
there may not be a donald trump to cover
they're looking at a future where they
may have to masquerade as journalists
again but they're not going to of course
they're going to declare whichever
republican is on the next next on the
list is the new orange hitler
nikki haley will be the the indian
hitler or it'll be ron desantis the
florida man hitler
right it'll always be the next
republican will always justify the
media's malfeasance because they're
never going to change
their practices they're never going to
be introspective enough to recognize
that they are not in fact journalists
they're just activists masquerading hey
here is don lemon letting the cat out of
the bag
you know we're having a hard time
getting over the fact that we've spent
the last four years
targeting this guy and then he may not
be there for us to bounce off of
this is like give us a while here in the
news
media because you know we have to we
gotta learn how to quit
the other person right it's like a
breakup we gotta get the other president
the other out of our phone contacts so
we can stop
talking about right now he's flailing
everything is flailing flailing failing
i'm just here to tell you it's going to
be okay
he's just failing okay but the reality
is what he says at the very beginning
they're having a hard time breaking up
with trump which shows the game
right the game for the media was always
using trump as a baton to club
everybody who disagrees the facts don't
matter
to our media to our steam media let's
just be clear about this
the facts are secondary to the narrative
okay so this became perfectly obvious
there's a game that's being played right
now and this is a dangerous game it's
been played by the media for a while or
facts are secondary to the narrative
right whatever the story is if the story
cuts against republicans it is a good
story if the story cuts against
democrats it is a bad story
not only is it a bad story it is now
deemed misinformation the media
have played this game particularly with
social media
where they have declared that anything
they don't like is misinformation
they've expanded the term misinformation
from false stories to things we don't
like this is how you got the hunter
biden story censored by social media
and by other media outlets for three
weeks leading up to the election
and the new york post's twitter account
suspended by twitter for a story that
was not factually untrue
right this is the game this is again the
narrative for the media
matter because they are activists
understand this journalists your
objective journalistic crew
they are not journalists they are
activists they are activist masquerading
as journalists
okay and not only that they have decided
that they are going to use
their journalistic bona fides in order
to pressure social media
and other outlets into quashing people
who disagree with them
so your objective journalists will say
over at cnn or msnbc or the new york
times they'll say things like
you know daily wire which is probably
the most popular right wing site on the
internet
daily wire my my outlet that you know
they they're very biased
they're not objective news they're
really not a news outlet they're more of
an opinion outlet
and and they're they're misinformation
and then we'll say okay you need to show
us like what we said that is untrue
i said well it's from a conservative
angle right we say that it's from a
conservative angle say yeah yeah but
it's misinformation
like well no it's not misinformation
we're actually more honest than you are
because we say exactly what we are while
you masquerade
and then these media outlets they go to
the social media heads
and they say because we called it
misinformation and because we are
objective we have declared ourselves
objective
you should stop the dissemination of
this misinformation
you should downgrade the material this
is the game here
right anything is justified so long as
you're fighting the fascists and the
fascists are all people you disagree
with
a perfect example of this yesterday and
and social media heads go for this by
the way
social media heads at facebook and and
twitter and at youtube
they buy this they're just looking for
an excuse they have a bunch of woke
staffers
and they are looking for an excuse to
please their woke staffers by lying and
labeling stuff
that cuts against the woke and cuts
against the left misinformation
perfect case in point example yesterday
kevin roose who is an activist okay he
is not a tech journalist he calls
himself a tech columnist for the new
york times
and he's just he's garbage at his job
every single day
kevin roos tweets out the most highly
trafficked links
on facebook or the most engaged links on
facebook
and usually it's a bunch of conservative
links and the reason for that is because
conservatives
have no other place to gather their news
other than via conservative outlets on
facebook
because the fact is that the new york
times is not not a single trump voter
that i am aware of works at the new york
times
not one right nobody works at cnn who's
an open trump voter not one face on the
network is an open trump voter
at least not anybody who's not like a a
contributor they just bring on to badger
okay so here is the game kevin roose
tweets those things out there he tweets
out a list
of engagement and it'll show like us
staley wire ben shapiro's facebook page
dan bongino
mark levin right that's what it'll show
and then he will direct that at facebook
and he'll say you guys are obviously
biasing your algorithm
how could you allow the dissemination of
this sort of conspiratorial material now
he never actually has to show why that
material is bad
in fact even if the material is true he
treats it as false
and then the social media bros they're
like oh well if kevin roose says so we
have to listen to kevin roos he works
for the new york times
or they go over to their friends over at
politifact or snopes or factcheck.org
all leftist interest groups who don't
bother in fact
to fact check they implicate the
implication check
or the narrative check and then there
are these social media heads
rely on the fact-checking organizations
to rule that something is false when it
isn't in fact false
and then they downgrade all the material
they don't like right this is the little
game they play
so yesterday kevin roos tweeted out
facebook is absolutely teeming
with right-wing misinformation right now
these are all among the 10 most engaged
urls on the platform over the last 24
hours per news whip
okay and then he tweets out the links
here are the titles of the links
republican in michigan goes from loser
to winner after technical glitch fixed
officials urge confidence in system
that's from us over at daily wire
a.g william barr authorizes doj to look
into voting irregularities that's from
breitbart
michigan legislature holds rare
emergency session to investigate in
election irregularities that's from dan
bongino
perdue loffler call on georgia secretary
of state to resign over election
that's from breitbart he says that these
are all right-wing misinformation
there's only one problem not one of
those titles is inaccurate
every single one of those is factual
every single title is factual
and so i pointed this out i pointed out
that the goal here for kevin roose is
not to police misinformation or bad data
the goal is to bully and club social
media
into downgrading conservative outlets so
here is how kevin rush responded and
this is the whole ball game folks when
it comes to the media
this is the whole ball game he he
responded
for the conservatives who are mad about
this yes it is possible for a story to
be factually accurate
and for it to be part of a
misinformation campaign aimed at
undermining confidence in an election
so in other words he's saying all these
stories are accurate all of them are
factual but i don't like the implication
of the stories
therefore facebook should downgrade them
i don't like the narrative that is
forwarded by these stories
therefore facebook should censor them so
in other words if it doesn't match a
narrative i don't like i'm just going to
ignore it i'm going to pretend that it
is a lie and then i'm going to call on
social media
to censor it i'm going to call on our
newspapers not to cover it
right this is the game and it is the
most dangerous game when i say that the
media rigged this last election
again i don't mean that they changed the
balloting what i mean is that they lied
about the narratives
and they promoted stories that were
designed to forward the narratives and
they
and they completely destroyed stories
that were factual that undercut the
narrative
right that's what the media did that's
why the media are garbage they are
garbage
they are unfixably garbage when kevin
roose
acknowledges overtly that it is possible
for a story to be factually accurate and
for him to call it misinformation anyway
because it is part of a quote unquote
misinformation campaign aimed at
undermining confidence in an election
he's making the agenda perfectly obvious
if it does not match kevin roose's
political priors
if it doesn't match the new york times
or the cnn or msnbc's political priors
well then it isn't news right it's
unfactual we're just going to ignore
those stories or pretend that they're
false or we'll call them misinformation
now let me just point out by kevin
ruse's standard donald trump is 190
correct in calling the new york times
fake news right because under donald
trump's standard
the new york times is constantly
printing stories many of which are
factually true but forward a false
narrative
so for example the new york times for
years printed anonymous allegations
about donald trump and russian collusion
did it turn out that that was all false
yes it turned out there was no russian
collusion
that's what the mueller report found
okay how about the new york times
promoting the
the narrative of systemic racism right
they print stories
that are factually true on their face
but don't go further
than our but don't go far enough to
actually include the relevant
details and then they forward a
narrative
that doesn't mean the story is factually
untrue it doesn't mean i'm calling for
the new york times to be censored
but folks on the left do call for
censorship folks on the left are looking
for social media to prevent you
from seeing the information you want to
see this is the goal
okay this is not a mistake kevin roos is
being very very open about this
the pressure tactics are on the media
are garbage
and the media are attempting to leverage
social media to shut down anybody they
don't like
that is what you are seeing in real time
right now that's why the media are so
invested in this coup narrative
because again the coup narrative allows
them to suppress information they don't
like because after all if you're
stopping hitler you can suppress bad
information
right you have to prevent the nazis from
getting their message out what if they
aren't nazis what if they're just people
who disagree with you
and what if they're saying is actually
true we'll get to all of this
and and more in just one second because
it turns out they're not just targeting
conservative news
they're not just targeting you and
preventing you from seeing the
information you want to see
they're targeting individuals who have
the temerity to just disagree
it's not about it's not even about
pretending it's misinformation anymore
they're just going after people who they
think disagree in any way
at all we're gonna get to more of this
in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that if
you're a business owner and you're
trying to call people it's a mistake
right people don't like picking up the
phone
anymore and most emails if especially if
they're from
your business to a customer they end up
in the spam folder here's what you need
to do you need to be using text messages
97 of text messages you get open 90 are
open within three minutes
you need to be texting your customers if
you're spending time on the phones
scheduling appointments you need podium
if you're sending invoices in the mail
you need podium if you need to convert
more sales from your website
you need podium podium is a business
messaging tool that gets you off the
phone into texting i can't tell you how
many times i've responded to a text from
my business
but every time the business calls me it
goes straight to voicemail podium brings
all your messages into one centralized
inbox your whole team can access letting
you save time
while responding to customers faster if
you need more reviews on google or
facebook you text it if you need an
invoice
you text it if you got to schedule an
appointment just send a text and this is
super helpful to your business it will
make it more effective and more
efficient for a limited time
sign up for 20 off your plan podium is
so confident
that if you don't make your business
better within 90 days with podium they
will send you a 150
amazon gift card for the holidays so no
risk head on over to podium.com shapiro
to get started that is 20
off if you go to p-o-d-i-u-m-podium.com
shapiro and make your business more tech
savvy with text messaging go to
podium.com
shapiro today okay we're going to get to
the actual allegations of voter fraud
we're going to get to the
targeting of people who disagree
individuals who disagree not just media
outlets like mine
but individuals who disagree like you
we're going to get to that in just one
second first
if you weren't already disgusted by the
legacy media you absolutely should be
now
the media preemptively called the
election in favor of joe biden
and now they're claiming that trump is
cooing because he is not conceding even
though the legal process has not yet
played out
but just because cnn or msnbc or fox
news declares something that doesn't
actually make it true
it means that they are pushing a
narrative not only that the media have
already shifted from demonizing
trump and his supporters to flattering
biden and harris before they've even
taken office i mean they went from
we are the rabid watchdogs on behalf of
democracy democracy dies in darkness too
can we lick your they went they went
real fast from one to the other
the dust hasn't even settled we're
already reading stories about joe's
rescue dogs and jill's stunning wardrobe
if you are sick of the media feeding you
the narrative replace your cable and
your new subscriptions head on over to
daily wire right now we have
big plans for the next four years we are
the replacement media it starts today
candace owens new york times
best-selling author founder of the
blexit foundation
is joining the daily wire she'll be
launching a brand new show with us early
next year
we are also launching an entertainment
channel a new investigative journalism
team we are building partnerships with
like-minded content creators like
prageru
whose entire show library will be
available to dailywire.com members by
the end of the year
we are going after legacy media we are
providing you an alternative we're going
to do it by building a huge membership
base of supporters like you and right
now just to show you we're serious we
are offering 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com
subscribe members get our articles ad
free access to all of our live
broadcasts and show library the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show
exclusive readers past content available
only to daily members
if you're considering that all access
membership you get to join us on all
access live every single night for live
stream discussions with our hosts and an
amazing online community
you also get not one but two leftist
years tumblers with your membership as
well as early sometimes exclusive access
to new daily wire products so remember
that's 25 off all memberships with code
election over at dailywire.com
subscribe replace the legacy
establishment media with daily wire you
won't regret it you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
alrighty so it's not just that the media
promote false narratives it's not just
that they push for the suppression
of narratives they don't like even if
those narratives happen to be backed by
the fact
it is also that the left in general is
now targeting individuals
now we've known this for a while right
you've felt this in your business you
work at a
i can't tell you the number of letters
and calls i receive along these lines
i work i mean from prominent people i
work at this company i work in this
industry and people
are are basically threatening to
blackball me unless i do exactly what
they want me
to do and this is cheered on it's shirt
on so the garbage people over at the
lincoln project have decided they are
now going after
jones and day right jones day jones day
is one of the biggest law firms in the
country
they tweeted out yesterday employees of
jones day and porter wright
do you believe your law firm should be
attempting to overturn the will of the
american people
according to law.com the american lawyer
the lincoln project a political action
committee founded by former republican
figureheads
is pledging to spend at least hundred
thousand dollars on an advertising blitz
vowing to target jones day and porter
right morrison arthur for their role as
council to the pennsylvania republican
party
and president trump respectively as they
bring unsupported claims of voter fraud
in the 2020 election right again they
are threatening
jones day and in fact the lincoln
project was attempting to out individual
lawyers they were saying you should
harass the lawyers at jones day for
representing the pennsylvania republican
party in court now
by the way that is the lawsuit that is
most likely to succeed right the
pennsylvania republican party is suing
because they say that the supreme courts
in man that the courts in
in pennsylvania basically
usurped the legislative authority in
lengthening
the election by allowing ballots
arriving after election day
still to be counted even if they did not
have proper postmarks and now
the lincoln project is going after the
lawyers now let me just be frank about
this
okay i've worked in big law okay big law
is a democratic repository
i would say that 80 percent of people
who work in big law are democrats
it is it is a very very democratic
industry doesn't matter lincoln project
is still going after jones day for
having the temerity to represent the
client
so jones day actually had to put out a
statement yesterday because of all this
nonsense
he said jones day is not representing
president trump his campaign or any
affiliated party in any litigation
alleging voter fraud
jones day is also not representing any
entity in any litigation challenging or
contesting the results of the 2020
general election jones day is
representing the pennsylvania gop in
pending litigation brought by private
parties in april 2020 and the
pennsylvania democratic party in august
2020.
in that litigation the pennsylvania
supreme court issued an order extending
the statutory deadline to return it
mail-in ballots established by the
pennsylvania general assembly
the case presents an important and
recurring rule of law question under the
u.s constitution
jones day will not withdraw from that
representation
jones day expects the media will correct
the numerous false reports given the
facts set forth above
yeah uh they're they're not okay the
media will not retract any of that stuff
don't expect anybody to back off the
lincoln project for a bunch of grifters
seeking to make a bunch of democratic
money
in the aftermath of failing inside the
republican party
so this is why when you hear joe biden
call for unity when you hear from
members of the media declaring a bright
new dawn
an era of good feelings yeah no no
i'm sorry you guys are too invested in
destroying your political opposition for
there to be an era of good feelings
i don't believe you i am skeptical of
your calls for unity i think by unity
you mean shut the hell up
and we're not going to shut the hell up
we have no intention of shutting the
hell up
we're not going to stop saying true
things because they don't fit your
narrative
kevin roos we are not going to stop
printing material that happens to be
true
even though facebook doesn't like it and
by the way we are not going to be
protecting the tech bros if the tech
bros decide that they are going to
suppress
material on behalf of the kevin russes
and kara swishers and juggler gambler
of the world we're not going to do that
okay this is a pressure campaign by the
media
to shift the nature of american politics
and you cannot go along with it and we
will not go along with it either
but inside the democratic party that
pressure campaign
is on the march okay that pressure
campaign is not just on the march inside
the
the media battle it's on it's on the
march inside the democratic party
the woke have basically declared war on
everyone who is not completely woke
inside the democratic party
rashida to leave in the squad are going
to war against any democrat who suggests
maybe it's a bad idea to alienate
half the american public by calling them
racist sexist and bigots for not liking
socialism
according to politico rashida talib
isn't apologizing for wanting to yank
money away from bad police departments
she has no second thoughts about her
embrace of the black lives matter
movement or for wanting to aggressively
fight climate change
house democrats lost seats instead of
expanding their majority underperforming
expectations across the board
and moderates have pounced on liberals
like talib a pounced pounce
the michigan congresswoman accusing them
of handing conservatives a set of
slogans and policies to scare voters
but to leave and other house
progressives don't want to hear it it
all amounts to unfair blame casting
designed to shame them into staying
quiet they say
right as democrats gain control of the
white house we're not going to be
successful for silencing districts like
mine said talib
me not being able to speak on behalf of
many of my neighbors right now many of
which are black
neighbors means me being silenced i
can't be silent you see
if you opposed or she did to leeb's
ridiculous and radical agenda even
inside the democratic party this means
you are a racist
she said we are not interested in unity
that asks people to sacrifice their
freedom and their rights any longer
right so this is the thing she doesn't
want unity with 70 million americans who
voted for trump she doesn't even want
unity
with the vast majority of the democratic
party who did not vote for rashida talib
and she wants dominance so do the media
they also want dominance
and they will use the same slurs that
they have used against republicans even
against democrats see
this is the beauty of the woke at least
their purity test applies to their own
party
in fact there's a letter that went out
yesterday from new deal strategies the
justice democrats
sunrise movement and data for progress
these are some of the most radical
groups inside
the democratic caucus there's a letter
that went out
to various democrats and to the media
what went wrong for congressional
democrats in 2020
their answer was that they didn't go
radical enough
and that if you disagree with them you
are in fact a vicious and horrifying
racist
they say over the last half century
republicans have harnessed strategic
racism to divide the electorate
too often democrats shy away from
conversations about race and keep issues
of economic justice and racial justice
in separate silos
republican attacks levied at democrats
this cycle based on terms like defund
the police or socialism
have become scapegoats for
representatives like abigail spanberg or
conor lam and other senior democrats
not a single democrat progressive or
otherwise argued that democrats should
run primarily on these themes
moreover these attacks will never go
away nor will demands for reform from
social movements
the attacks are designed to stoke racial
resentment which is core to the gop's
election strategy
our party should not feed into it
conservative democrats may change the
terms and people we blame and fear year
by year but democrats must take on the
republican party's divide and conquer
racism head on
and not demobilize our own base
okay so the good news is at least the
woke are attacking even people inside
their own party
so the media have fallen to the woke the
social media have fallen into the woke
the woke are taking on democrats inside
their own party that is the battle of
the future
okay the battle of the future is going
to be over whether you even get to see
the material you want to see
over whether you get to treat your
friends and neighbors as friends and
neighbors this is why
pasting over all of these deep
philosophical conflicts
right conflicts i talk about in my book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps go pick it up today
pasting over those deep philosophical
conflicts with grandpa simpson over here
at joe biden it ain't gonna work it's
why the media are militantly refusing to
listen to joe biden when joe biden is
like listen there's a process and the
process will play out
no one no one cares what joe biden has
to say because the battle has moved
beyond joe biden joe biden may have been
a last-gasp attempt by democrats
to basically stop the battle from from
raging but joe biden doesn't have the
stones to actually stand up to his own
party
joe biden doesn't have the stones to
tell michelle obama to be quiet when she
says things like
70 million americans are motivated by
hate and chaos and racism
he doesn't have the stones for that
nobody in the democratic party has the
stones for that
and so what this is going to come down
to is a battle to suppress
the media are going to continue pushing
narratives they know are false because
it justifies their behavior
members of the democratic party are
going to continue to justify
their lies that americans are broadly
speaking racist because it justifies
their strategy
and you are going to be the only people
standing in the bridge and we are going
to be standing with you in the breach
that is the battle for the next decade
the battle for the next decade is will
they be able to shut you up
will they be able to tell you that
because you are a racist sexist bigot
homophobe
you need to be shut up will they be able
to say that things that are factually
true are factually false because they do
not agree with their narrative
will they be able to take control of all
the institutions to such an extent that
you are forced not only to be quiet but
to mirror their political priorities
because here's the thing we went real
fast in this country from why can't we
just have polite conversations about
politics please stop being so
so militant in your in your pursuit of
conservatism
two silences violence we went real fast
from one to the other didn't we
the progression went like this you
conservatives you should be more polite
and conservatives are like okay
and then it went to well you shouldn't
just be polite you should shut up right
you should be silent
in fact stay silent for your own safety
and many conservatives because they felt
like they were being browbeaten were
like
i guess okay and now the message is if
you do not literally repeat
the words we are saying to you right now
and agree that they are true
then we will castigate you as an enemy
if you refuse to say right now
president-elect biden because he is not
in fact president-elect biden you are
the enemy if you used to say
america's systemically racist you are
the enemy if you don't post a black
square on your facebook page you are the
enemy
if you refuse to post the the
tautological semantically overloaded
lawn sign on your lawn
you are the enemy that is the battle the
battle for the future is this culture
war it is the reason trump was elected
in 2016
it's the reason why democrats did not
see the the vast amount of support that
not only trump or republicans across the
country had in 2020
that battle is not going to abate
anytime soon okay now
let's talk a little bit about the actual
voter fraud allegations that are still
out there
so yesterday the former nevada ag
detailed some voter fraud allegations
here was the former nevada ag talking
about it
do you have specific sworn allegations
absolutely absolutely
so the attorney general has been
attacking me for a week without evidence
and he tweeted today
that now we don't have there's not
evidence of widespread voter fraud so
they've backed off the fact that there's
zero voter fraud now they're saying we
haven't produced
enough we're outside of the system this
is a needle in a haystack type situation
we've produced dead voters we've also
produced over three thousand people that
moved out of las vegas
this year and still voted in this
election
okay so is there evidence in a country
of 150 million people of voter fraud
sure and voter regularity sure again the
legal burden as i keep saying is very
very high here the trump campaign has to
show not just that there was voter fraud
but also
that it impacted the outcome of the
election because the voter deficits in
many of these states are tens of
thousands of votes
it makes it difficult to prove that one
of the controversial cases that came up
yesterday was one of a pennsylvania
postal worker originally this
pennsylvania postal worker named richard
hopkins he claimed that a postmaster in
erie pennsylvania instructed postal
workers to back date ballots
mailed after election day i talked about
this on the show yesterday
attorney general william barr authorized
federal prosecutors to open probes into
credible allegations well according to
the washington post on monday
hopkins 32 told investigators from the
u.s postal service's office of inspector
general the allegations weren't true
he signed an affidavit recanting his
claims democrats on the house oversight
committee tweeted
late on tuesday that the whistleblower
completely recanted hopkins did not
respond to messages from
the washington post but in a youtube
video he posted tuesday night he then
denied recounting
he said i'm here to say i did not recant
my statement that did not happen
so who do you believe i don't know who
to believe
okay but bottom line is you'd have to
prove the allegations anyway
the postal worker again said later on
video that he had been pressured
into into recanting in some way
right james o'keefe tweeted out we have
recordings of the federal agents who
coerced this man through a four-hour
interrogation without representation who
stands by his original affidavit
regarding back dating ballots stand by
for recordings doubling down
on back dating ballots this is soviet
style truth suppression
u.s official stands by his original
affidavit
earlier this week of course senator
senate judiciary committee chairman
lindsey graham urged the doj and the
postmaster general to look
into the allegations from hopkins later
on tuesday night i'll keep dropped video
of hopkins claiming he did not recount
his allegations and would like a
retraction from the washington post
he said you'll find out tomorrow he said
i'd like the washington post to recount
their wonderful little article they
decided to
throw out there then in another post
okay published a video of hopkins
allegedly being pressed by agent russell
strasser and later telling o'keefe he
still stands
by his claim one of the quotes agent
strasser i'm trying to twist you a
little bit
so he uh he apparently has been placed
on
non-pay status by the postal service so
we will bring you new details of that
story as they arise meanwhile
the allegheny board of elections voted
on tuesday to count more than 2 300
ballots that do not have dates on the
outer envelope
according to numerous local news sources
again
are these numbers that would shift the
election in trump's favor
probably not but if you are worried
about voter fraud voter irregularity you
should be worried about this story
the ballots which have not been opened
all arrived on or before election day as
they are stamped to the date when they
are received according to elections
employees
trib live.com reported the board of
elections made up of allegheny county
executive rich fitzgerald
councilman sam demarco and councilwoman
bethany hallam voted 2-1 to count those
votes after a brief discussion
demarco voted against the motion
they are stamped with the date when they
are received of course but they are not
stamped
with the outer with the postmark on the
ballot apparently the exact number of
ballots that did not have dates on them
was 2
349. fox news
notes that the law in the state says the
ballot mailing envelope has to contain
the date
and that tens of thousands of ballots
had still not been counted in
pennsylvania
well the good news is at least the new
york times called up the various
election officials and got them to say
there was no evidence of voter frauds
that's exciting stuff
because i know that the new york times
usually takes officials at their word
this is what the new york times does
now let's say the new york times has a
story that something bad has happened
inside the trump administration usually
they then call up the trump official
and if the official says it didn't
happen the new york times goes oh okay
and just moves on with their day or
alternatively that is not how any of
this works the new york times has a
piece today called the times called
officials in every state
no evidence of voter fraud oh you mean
the people who are in charge of
overseeing elections
say that they did a good job well then
everything's hunky-dory i guess
again every allegation a voter fraud
that is credible should be investigated
this is what the doj says this is what
reason tells you
the likelihood that it will impact the
outcome of the election is not
particularly high
but the notion that if you ask a
question about it that this means that
you are bad
and you have to be suppressed is of
course incredibly incredibly silly
nonetheless that is exactly what the new
york times is now saying
the new york times suggests election
officials in dozens of states
representing both political parties said
there was no evidence that fraud
or other irregularities played a role in
the outcome of the presidential race
amounting to a forceful rebuke of
president trump's portrait of a
fraudulent election
over the last several days the president
members of his administration
congressional republicans and right-wing
allies have put forth the false claim
that the election was stolen from mr
trump and have refused to accept results
that showed joe biden
as the winner but top election officials
across the country said in interviews
and statements
the process had been a remarkable
success despite record turnout and the
complications of a dangerous pandemic
okay just a quick note here if joe biden
had lost do you think this would be the
story
let's say that joe biden had lost and
let's say that joe biden said guys i
think they're voter regularities or in
the words of joe biden
trouble down and goes yeah boom let's
say that he had said that
you think the new york times calls up
all the election officials and they all
say it's clean and then they're like
why won't you abide and concede i i
again have serious doubts about our
mainstream media very very serious
doubts about the establishment media
but suddenly the election is fair and
clean remember up until the last two
weeks of the election
the narrative from democrats is that
trump is going to seal the election by
burning mailboxes that louis de joy the
postmaster general
was taking mailboxes out of circulation
and decommissioning machines
that were able to sort mail-in ballots
like that was the narrative
it was all preset if biden had lost that
was going to be the narrative was voter
suppression
and trump messing around with the
balloting but if trump loses and then
trump has questions about voter fraud
and voter irregularities or anybody else
does
then suddenly that's very bad because
abs the election officials say it's
clean so guys i guess that it's all
clean i guess that we are all good to go
here
okay uh again none of this means that
trump will be declared the winner of the
election or that the election results
will be reversed
we don't know yet it is unlikely
with that said the the media's eagerness
to put this thing to bed
betrays a a different agenda i do not
think that they are in it for the good
of the country or the protection of
democracy i think they're in it for
their own skins and the preservation of
the narrative that says that their
political enemies are in
in fact still deplorables they do not
have to investigate or understand
in any way okay we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam scievent
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
bench shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. you know the
matt wall show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about
hope you'll give it a listen
you